in 2012 I was returning from pretty  successful tournament in Argentina back  to the US and decided to play a small  tournament in bahamas along the way we  just landed two hours before the whole  region was closed to hurricane sandy for  pretty much a week we were stuck in a  huge hotel literally stuck there because  you know outside pressure was so high  that you know hand drawn up man couldn't  open the door to toe you know outside  and there's no power and there is a  priest Harris food supply but they had  to play the tournament and so for the  first time in my life I played entirely  by a candle light from the round one the  little hex round and I want that  tournament that you know something to  remember forever